-Welcome back to the show.
Thank you for being here.
I appreciate this.
When you guys
started this -- in 1984?
-[ Laughs ] Yes.
-We don't remember.
We think so.
-Did you see yourselves
being together in 2022 in '84?
Or you don't think that far --
-40 years later?
No, I am pretty sure -- Like --
I'm pretty sure the only reason
we're still together
40 years later
is because suicide pacts
apparently are not binding.
-Wow!
-That, and we're Canadian.
It's too impolite to break up.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-It makes a lot of noise.
-That's why the divorce rate
in Canada is zero.
-No, it doesn't --
Everyone's too polite.
Here's you guys here.
Look at these.
-Ah.
-Aww.
-Look how cute we are.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, you just want throw us
over your shoulder and burp us.
-Really just want
to burp you guys.
I've obviously loved you.
But I think I know you, but you
guys didn't even start together.
Is that correct? You were
different sketch groups?
-Yes, we were two different
sketch groups.
We were The Audience...
-From Calgary!
-...which was Mark's name.
A lot of Calgarians here.
-We were the Kids in the Hall
in Toronto.
-Yep.
-Whoo!
-And --
-Some guy.
-And some guy.
-I was an actor.
-Oh, of course!
-I was a real actor.
-Exactly, Scott, yes.
And how did you all
end up coming together
and forming the band?
-Scott booted his way in.
-Well, they'd all been together.
And I saw them one night
in a midnight show.
And my friend Darlene
dragged me down.
And we were in an audience.
There was about seven people.
And they weren't doing
that well.
And there wasn't really anybody
in the audience
to let them know
how badly they were doing,
but I fell in love with them
right away.
And I thought to myself,
"I need to be in that group."
And I noticed
underneath the chair,
there was a doughnut taped --
-From a really bad scene idea.
-Then I found some other
doughnuts taped in other seats.
And I went, "Oh, I bet those
doughnuts are part of a bit.
Maybe I should ruin the bit.
[ Laughter ]
And then they'll see me."
And you want to be seen.
-Of course!
-So I grab the doughnuts
and I just started whipping it
at them on stage.
And I remember Bruce going,
"What the [bleep]...?"
[ Laughter ]
I go like,
"It's me! I'm here!"
-"Your new friend!"
-I just wanted them
to notice me.
And it could have gone
a lot worse though.
-It went pretty bad.
-It was bad, but --
This part,
they don't even know, really.
Buy I had a cross bow
with me, as well. People --
-It could have been much worse.
-Well, I just came
from a Renn fair.
I was going to fire bolts
just above their heads,
so, luckily,
I went for the doughnuts.
-Doughnuts.
Always go for the doughnuts.
-Thank you.
-And now here we are.
-And did -- did you
all get discovered by Lorne?
Like, how did that --
'Cause I know
I auditioned for Lorne Michaels.
But did he -- did he find you?
Or did he -- how did that work?
-Well, he actually sent people
to Toronto
when we were doing a show,
and it was the week we got
a really rave review
in "The Globe and Mail,"
which is a newspaper
up in Canada.
And so we're actually
at the theater
rehearsing after
this rave review
and I'm probably reading it
over and over.
And then the phone rang,
and it was the talent bookers
from "Saturday Night Live."
They said, "Oh, we read
about your show.
We want to come." And I said,
"Well, it's sold out."
[ Laughter ]
And then I said, "Well, maybe
we'll do a run in a year or so."
And I said, "Well, you're
from 'Saturday Night Live.'
You got a lot of money.
You can scalp tickets perhaps."
And then I hung up the phone.
And I looked over
at my four friends here
and realized
I did a wrong thing.
So I called the nice lady back,
and here we are, yeah.
-Yeah, and then he saw you
and said,
"Oh, yeah, you guys are great"?
-Yeah, we had Lorne --
Eventually,
Lorne came up and saw one
of our shows in Toronto.
And you know -- you know Lorne.
Lorne's a laugher.
He's so easy to make laugh.
And Lorne has a beautiful laugh.
-Did he -- Did he laugh?
-Oh, he laughed.
Lorne has like -- He laughs
like an old-timey cowboy.
Like the chuck-wagon cook.
All they way through the --
he was just going --
[ Wheezing laughter ]
"By gum!"
Yeah, the whole crowd
was staring at him.
No one really paid attention
to us at all.
-So he didn't laugh at all?
-No.
-He didn't laugh at all.
-He looked bemused
several times.
-At least he stayed
for the whole thing.
-Yeah, he did stay --
Well, not the whole thing.
I think --
-No.
We did like a 3-hour show.
-We did like a 3-1/2-hour show.
-Yeah.
-And then, afterwards,
at the half, I went up to him
and said,
"And now, Lorne, guess what.
After the break,
we're gonna do some improv.
Do you want to stick around?"
And he was like...
[As Michaels] "Hmm.
Do I want to stick around
to watch improv?
Uh, over my dead body?"
-Yeah, no.
And -- Yeah, but anyways,
you end up being --
and working together and became
the Kids in the Hall.
Mark, I don't know if you
remember this years ago
I met you.
-Yes. 1996. That's right.
I was on "Saturday Night Live."
Someone asked me to do a student
film in Troy, New York,
in the middle of winter,
so, naturally, I said yes.
And I went up there, and there
was a sound guy doing the boom
who had a lot of energy.
Like, way, way too much energy.
And that was...Jimmy Fallon.
-I was excited, yeah.
-Oh, you were...
Boom's in the shot!
"I'm on it! I'm on it!"
-"Should I be in the shot,
as well?!"
-"Can I -- Can I get in?!
Is the camera...?"
-I remember I was laying
under a coffee table
for one scene or whatever,
and I was holding a microphone,
and you were doing a scene.
And I go, "Hey, Mark."
And you're like...
Doing your scene. You're like...
And I go...
-"Not now!"
-"I really want to be
on 'Saturday Night Live.'"
And you go, "Good luck, man.
It's going to be great."
-No, but we stayed in touch.
And then you sent -- By the way,
the sound on that film,
not great.
-I thought
that would be perfect.
-No, but then later,
you sent me a VHS tape
and a really sweet letter
and said
could I pass it along
to someone.
-Yeah, I appreciate that.
You were great to me.
You were really nice.
Why -- Why bring it back now?
Why -- Is it just demand?
Everyone wants to see
the Kids in the Hall now?
-Well, my astrologer told me
that one of us
was going to die soon.
-Oh. Wow.
-And I'm the weak one, so...
[ Laughter ]
-I actually paid his astrologer
to say that.
-To say that --
-It was worth it.
It was worth it.
-This is a --
This is a photo I have from
season five here.
This is -- You guys were
all buried together.
-Yeah.
-Can we see this one? Yeah.
It was very funny.
It's not shocking. It's funny.
-It's funny.
-Here's what's good, is --
Season six, you guys
are back from the dead.
In the exact same outfits.
The exact same positions.
It's so rad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Well, I can assume at this
point there's going to be --
There's going to be even more
"Kids in the Hall."
Are you working
on a seventh season?
-Uh, we're told
it really all depends
how well this interview goes.
-Yeah, so, in a word --
in a word, no.
-No? Yeah.
I cannot wait for this.
I'm so excited.
This Friday on Amazon Prime.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at the new season
of "Kids in the Hall."
Take a look.
-You ready to meet the fellas?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
=♪ We're fast, we're loose,
we're out of control ♪
♪ We're 60 years young
and on the pole ♪
[ Women screaming ]
-Oh, my God! It is so, so sexy.
And there's a real sense
of danger. Mostly for them.
Because they could
really get hurt.
-[ Women screaming ]
-Here he comes, ladies.
Look at the love
and his reading glasses.
♪♪
-I've been doing this since
they closed the Oshawa plant.
Autoworkers and strippers
are in the same union,
so, you know,
I got to keep my benefits.
-Oh, my God!
He still has a land line!
That's so hot.
[ Busy signal beeping ]
-"The Kids in the Hall,"
everybody.
-Not bad.
--The new season comes
to Prime Video this Friday.